[Musik]
ich habe langsam angst dass du meinen
kanal übernimmst du auch darf ich den
anfang machen darf ich die begrüßung
machen
oder möchtest du du hallo herzlich
willkommen zur sallys und l aus wels
bald nur noch eröffnet heute machen wir
was richtig leckeres und süßes und zwar
massiv im waffel becher die sind richtig
schön klein toll für eine party
geburtstagsparty kindergeburtstag
faschingsumzug halloween egal für welche
veranstaltung auch immer denn ihr habt
hier diese süßen kleinen becher und die
gibt es eigentlich in jedem supermarkt
ich glaube viele kennen die als
eisbecher oder auch ein becher und die
kann man essen
das heißt man spart sich ja auch das
papier der hat erwarte wir müssen
erstmal die zutaten vorstellen also das
darfst du jetzt halt machen
rang zwei
das große und zucker backpulver natron
[Musik]
der moment wenn dein kind zur tat
richtig ausspricht und ich sag immer
kaka aber das ist falsch
das heißt wirklich so wie du sagst kakao
und eis besser und wir haben hier
buttermilch und sonnenblumen und die
genauen mengen die stehen einfach in der
app und auf dem blog ok also ella
wir machen das jetzt so pater hatte ich
habe hier die flüssigen zutaten und du
dir trockenen okay also erhöht jetzt
einfach die flüssigen zutaten in einer
großen schüssel
wir trocknen wird dann in der kleineren
schüsseln tritt einfach alle hier rein
ich nehme die flüssigen okay weil dann
sieht man bei dir nämlich besser was du
machst in der gasse und ich gebe dir die
flüssigen reihen okay die große ja
buttermilch oder auch normale milch
nehmen wir nehmen sie normale in willich
habt dann gibt aber noch einen schuss
zitronensaft mir dazu oder einem schuss
essig ausschuss jetzt muss ich warten
sturm ihr denken also einfach nicht erst
lassen zb und ich mache ja du kriegst
den slr genau den schneebesen und jetzt
versuche ich hier die zutaten einfach so
und muffins machen ist ganz einfach per
da braucht man keine küchenmaschine
dafür ist nur ein handtuch zum service
super auch super gar nicht schlimm
jetzt müssen wir nämlich sowieso die
flüssigen und die trockenen verloren
hatte hier rein jetzt kannst du es hier
ein schütten befreien
jetzt einfach nur bei zu vermischen die
flüssigen und die trockene miteinander
und das war
zubereitungszeit des tages eine minute
ja da war spielt eine schlafmütze jedem
video zeigt dass sie doch nicht so ganz
geschmeidig aus wahrscheinlich weil die
buttermilch so kalt war
ich gebe noch mal ein bisschen butter
mensch dazu erwärmt die aber vorher kurz
und dann wird der schönen homogen also
wenn er so aussieht einfach ein bisschen
was warmes dazugeben und dann wär das
schön glatt
wenn ich kann jetzt mal die waffe becher
nehmen und da wirklich auch darauf
achten dass er die waffe becher mit
schokolade nimmt denn durch die
schokolade haftet der teig dann auch
unter koch und eben später auch an der
waffel ansonsten würde nach dem backen
nämlich einfach wieder raus fallen also
die schokolade dient hier als kleber so
fragen geschafft
[Musik]
da steckst du jetzt einmal als systeme
immer so eine waffe den kleinen ein
funktionär und dann kommt da einfach ein
bisschen was rein und weil wir später ja
noch sahne drauf machen reicht es auch
schon okay so wirklich nur hier bis zur
lisa unterkante
[Musik]
ich weiß mir hier in seeg und papa ja
die waffen besser wir hätten hier
gebacken und wenn sie dann aus dem ofen
kommen und abgekühlt sind geht es dann
da wird gleich weiter
[Musik]
die seen perfekt aus die stäbchen probe
habe ich eben schon gemacht bei einem
haps dann noch mal drei minuten nach
gestellt jetzt lasse ich sie abkühlen
und dann werden sie dekoriert
dankeschön fürs topping nämlich 50 gramm
sahne 100 gramm weiße schokolade von
dascom weiche butter 50 gramm
puderzucker und eine prise salz etwas
vanille extrakt um 350 gramm frisch
lesen ich koche jetzt zuerst die sahne
auf und gibt dann die schokolade dazu
so kann seine stelzen 54 jeweils
schokolade rhein wird kurz verrührt und
dann stelle ich das ganze gleich in den
kühlschrank damit einfach wieder
kühlschrank kalt wird es kommt zu kurz
in den waffenschrank auch nur noch
lauwarm
aber es muss jetzt wirklich schön wieder
kalt werden gebe ich schon mal die
weiche butter in eine schüssel und
stammen salz butter zucker dazu dann
noch etwas vanille extrakt jetzt einfach
für ein paar minuten schön verrühren bis
die butter schön weiß cremig ist
das ist damals die konsistenz wirklich
auch aus wenn man so in ein stück brot
abreißen würde wird die butter hat
patrick schmecken wenn man wirklich
lange verwirrt und schaumig wird dann
schmeckt sehr einfach sehr aromatischen
chemisch und deswegen wirklich hier
schön lange röhren für diverse
das kann hier die abgekühlte schokolade
dazu geben und das ist ein topping was
auch bei raumtemperatur wo schön
standfest bleibt deswegen habe ich jetzt
diese topping ausgesucht ihr könnt aber
wenn er sagt mensch ich habe großen
kühlschrank ich kann die cupcakes oder
die muffins darin lagern auch gerne an
sahnequark topping machen oder mit
mascarpone arbeiten aber ich finde gab
beim party buffet ist echt wichtig dass
man was wählt was wirklich auch mal ein
paar stunden bei raumtemperatur stehen
kann
die schoko sahne einrühren etwas vanille
extrakt dazu geben
und dann den frischkäse
da bräuchte es eine dritte hand jetzt
einfach kurz cremig rühren
die creme auch eine echt schöne
konsistenz und man kann da wirklich
nichts falsch machen man kann sie nicht
überschlagen
der einzige wäre der versenkung ist wenn
ihr die schokolade zu warm bezug gibt
dann wird die butter flüssig also da
wirklich darauf achten dass die
abgekühlt ist
aber ansonsten ist es wirklich eine
creme die jedem gelingt und jetzt gebe
ich dir einen spritzbeutel da habe ich
eine mittelgroße stern teile drauf was
auch glaube ich ganz hübsch ist wenn man
jetzt einfach noch mal den kleinen als
portionierer nimmt und wie so eine kugel
ab sticht und drauf sitzt wie so eine
eiskugel ja das sieht dann auch schön
aus ich glaube das könnte richtig cool
aussehen dafür müsste ich ja noch ein
bisschen kühlen die creme wenn man noch
ein bisschen kühlt dann hat seine
struktur okay machen jetzt nicht aber
auch eine politik muss ich mir merken
für snacks hier sieht man auch ganz gut
das ist wirklich schon gebraucht das
spritzbeutel hier vorne die kleine stern
thüle bzw die mittlere sperrt hülle und
jetzt hier ansetzen denn ich sehe zwar
ein weg spritzbeutel aber es sind
wirklich nervig spritzbeutel ihr könnt
ihr dann einfach auswaschen und vor
allem sind die einfach hygienisch sauber
ich hatte früher nämlich so ein
spritzbeutel aus zu einem textil stopp
innen beschichtet
da hat man das problem irgendwann ist
der stoff kaputt man muss es
wegschmeißen
und das ist einfach so ein verbundstoff
das heißt man kann es auch nicht
recyceln man kann gar nichts mehr daraus
machen und vor allem stinkt da
irgendwann wenn man ihn nicht richtig
abtrocknet deswegen nehme ich gern die
hier und benutzt die einfach mehrfach
und fertig da habt ihr wirklich immer
ein schönes sauberes ergebnis und jetzt
hier einfach ansetzen
[Musik]
und hier einfach schöne kleine
bewegungen machen und hochziehen und
dann entsteht ist tolle muster
[Musik]
hier kommen jetzt noch streusel drauf
nehmen jetzt einfach bunte streusel und
ich stelle jetzt aber kurz in den
kühlschrank damit sie schon mal fest
werden können dann behalten sie auch
ihre schöne form so etwa eine stunde und
gefärbt und dann können selber
haftbefehl
[Musik]
welche nimmst du da ich probier mal die
elf grad schon in ihrem zimmer rapunzel
spiel deswegen darf jetzt amira
verkosten und ist schon cool für einen
kindergeburtstag oder erwachsenen
geburtstag gab schon marschiert zur
seitlichen gibt es neue creme und muffin
aber kinder essen meistens immer erst
mal das topping runter und schmeckt gut
gab es auch recht cool und vor allem
sind die schnell gemacht man braucht
keine besondere backform man kauft
einfach nur dieser waffe becher es
entsteht kein müll mann ist aus der hand
und am ende bleibt nur noch die top und
natürlich perfekt würde ich sagen
man kann sie auch super mitnehmen und
wenn man die creme weglässt dann sind
sie auch komplett für den kindergarten
zum beispiel auch geeignet im
kindergarten hat man sich so gerne creme
aber da würde ich sie dann vielleicht im
schokoladen slogan drauf und fertig da
hat mal was richtig schön ist und vor
allem eine schöne kleine portion also
wenn ihr das gepäck nach machen wollt
dann schaut auch cds - blog.de vorbei
oder auch in meiner app die es kostenlos
da könnt ihr euch nämlich alle rezepte
anschauen könnt da die rezepte hoch und
runter rechnen
gerade wegen den mengenangaben wenn ihr
mehr oder weniger machen wollte und
könnte auch rezepte als vorrat speichern
und auch viele vieles lernen also viel
spaß für nachmachen und bis zum nächsten
mal
ja und ich find es die vier außen
vertreten ist der tag in trident racing
day after helfen dass eis bleibt hier
aber auch eltern möchten
[Musik]